après l'est et l'ouest ce soir on
s'intéresse aux enjeux préoccupation
économique de l'ontario à quelques jours
de l'élection fédérale à toronto on
reçoit robert hogue économiste principal
à la banque royale robert rob bonsoir
oui bonsoir
quel est l'enjeu selon-vous selon votre
vision des choses quel est l'enjeu
économique prioritaire en ontario ben si
vous parlez aux ménages je vous dirais
que la réponse que vous allez avoir un
peu partout c'est vraiment c'est du côté
du coût de la vie ou de le prix de
l'habitation tout particulièrement
on sait très bien que le prix
d'habitation augmenter beaucoup au cours
de la dernière décennie de saigner demi
alors se créer de fortes pressions mais
vivement que ça se traduise pas par des
pressions général d'ides en pole et les
ménages dans la région toronto du côté
des entreprises un peu comme à travers
le pays où six et les pénuries de main
d'oeuvre et beaucoup de pression pour
les entreprises qui est lorsqu'on se
promène et puis qu'on parle justement
aux jeunes entreprises seraient vient
toujours toujours sur la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre alors ce sont des pressions que
ces restes des deux côtés ici alors deux
grands sujets allons-y dans l'ordre avec
l'immobilier d'abord je voyais que
toronto et au 16e rang des villes du
monde où ça coûte le plus cher pour se
loger les partis politiques en vue du
tour de propositions là pour améliorer
l'accès à la propriété durant cette
campagne électorale
quels sont les lits les problèmes en
matière d'accès au logement à toronto
c'est évidemment c'est le coup ça s'est
vu le coup non seulement pour devenir
propriétaire m'a aussi du côté locatif
le le prix du loyer
non non seulement été levée mardi
beaucoup au cours des dernières années
le taux d'inoccupation est très très bas
dans la région de toronto tout
particulièrement mais aussi partout à
travers la province à ce qu'on regarde
même du côté d'ottawa puis dans ce
matériau donc ce sont des dépressions
l'ex ans qui sont vraiment généralisée
de ce côté là la construction ne suit
pas la demande
même si la construction est quand même
élevé en faux faux faux est fruit très
clair là dessus il ya eu beaucoup il ya
beaucoup d unités présentement en voie
de construction mais il à côté d
achèvement ça vient pas assez vite faut
bien comprendre que tout le sud de
l'ontario particulièrement encore une
fois dans les régions toronto la
croissance de population est très vive
lorsqu'on regarde l'année dernière par
exemple la région toronto la population
a augmenté de 125 mille personnes ce qui
est énorme évidemment ça crée de très
grande pression sur le le votre parc
d'habitation alors c'est pas une
surprise que des tensions tant du côté
locatif que du côté de la propriété
et puis c'est il faut vraiment que le du
côté de l'offre dont la construction non
seulement se soient élevées mais ce
segment est encore plus dense que c'est
dans un certain sens
pour ce qui est de la rareté de
main-d'oeuvre est ce que vous diriez que
ça ralentit l'économie les entreprises
ontariennes
c'est une grande question évidemment
nous les économies sont cela pose cette
question là on se pose sur paix que la
réponse soit oui dans une certaine
mesure
lorsqu'on est rendu à des taux de
chômage aussi bon il faut bien
s'entendre l'ontario tout juste un peu
sous les 5% ça c'est des niveaux qu'on a
pas vu qu'en vue très peu vu au cours
des 40 dernières années d'ailleurs le
québec aussi un taux de chômage très
très bonne on est en année ou au point
où vraiment
on entend de plus en plus d entreprises
qui disent qu'ils doivent soit notre
fermer certains camps de travail ou
fermer certaines jonathan c'est sûr que
si on entend ces étoiles au québec mais
c'est aussi le cas dans notariaux
également non seulement faut-il se loger
mais il faut aussi se déplacer
est ce que la question des transports
transports en commun infrastructures de
transport préoccupe les ontariennes oui
tout à fait je pense que c'est un savant
un peu d'allant tout ce contexte là de
coût de la vie parce que lorsqu'on gagne
surtout nous lorsqu'on regarde d'un
point de vue économique la mobilité la
capacité de pouvoir voir un endroit dans
une partie de la ville est plus
d'habiter dans une autre est limité
lorsque votre infrastructure un
transport est rendu à son maximum mais
je dirais que c'est plus que son maximum
alors c'est pas une surprise que des
investissements quand même massif qui se
font de ce côté là on voit le tout les
plans d'expansion dans les côtés du
train régional légalement du métro on a
eu des annonces encore au cours des
derniers jours au niveau provincial la
ccsa répondait besoin que des besoins
qui sont présents encore là je répète
une population qui a crû l'an dernier de
125000 c'est sur la région de toronto
s'ajoute dans tout le temps du côté
l'habitation que du côté de
l'utilisation d'une infrastructure dans
les transports et quand on parle de
toronto on parle d'une 9,05 qui est
autour le kaki autour de toronto si cool
poids économique de ce qu'on appelle le
9 05 en collégiale c'est énorme
lorsqu'on parle de population par
exemple la région toronto au total l'on
passe d'une population qui grosso modo
autour de 6 millions à l'extérieur de la
ville de toronto 7 3 2 millions à
l'avant parle d'un pouvoir qui a encore
plus grand que la ville même de toronto
donc c'est vraiment c'est énorme c'est
sans doute elle les régions rebelles
la plus grande au canada alors c'est
c'est un poids évidemment catena
l'ontario compte beaucoup sur le
commerce international les états unis la
chine est ce que cet enjeu été abordés
suffisamment en campagne cet excès dans
le contexte d'un contexte mondial où là
c'est ça dépasse les 1 peu la sphère
canadienne
dans une certaine mesure c'est il ya
beaucoup de choses qui se passent entre
les états unis la chine qui sont
présentement lorsqu'on parle de
décrépitude auprès des entreprises tous
secteurs la fabrication par exemple
s'inquiète beaucoup de situations à la
panne serment directement pour les
entreprises canadiennes vie plutôt
violent et les chaînes
d'approvisionnement l'aurions connaître
certaines perturbations
alors c'est sûr que c'est au coeur
l'aude et des inquiétudes des
entreprises non seulement notariaux là
mais je voudrais dans l'ensemble
l'ontario particulièrement patent donner
le lien très très très rapprochés avec
le marché américaine bien robert hogue
bonne fin de semaine bon vote à la
prochaine à la rochelle